bildung eines der dauerbrenner in der
berliner politik
kein thema wird in berlin wohl schon
seit jahren so stark diskutiert wie das
thema schule gerade geht es um den
lehrermangel berlin verbeamtet seine
lehrer schon länger nicht mehr kritiker
sprechen davon dass deswegen viele
lehrer die stadt verlassen und in andere
bundesländer gehen wir treffen gleich
eine schülerin die das thema
lehrermangel ziemlich stark beschäftigt
leoni krüger wohnt am berliner stadtrand
sie geht in die elfte klasse eines
gymnasiums wenn alles gut geht wird sie
kommendes jahr ihr abitur machen die 17
jährige spürt den lehrermangel deutlich
vor allem seit sie in der oberstufe ist
werde zu selten vertreten
die alltäglichste situation ist
sicherlich dass stunden ausfallen die
halt auch einfach wegfallen und nicht
ersetzt werden und auch über lenk wenn
lehrer in über längeren zeitraum
wirklich fehlen dass dann der
unterrichtsstoff einfach fehlt teilweise
der
fachleiter versucht dann so uns aufgaben
mitzugeben und uns mit irgendwie mit
durch zu haschen aber zumindest ist in
der oberstufe wirklich problematisch das
dann wirklich die stunden und der
unterrichtsstoff einfach weg bleibt und
fehlt leoni ist im berliner landes
schüler ausschuss aktiv regelmäßig
tauscht sie sich mit anderen
schülervertretern aus für sie sind auch
die vielen quer und seiteneinsteiger im
lehrerberuf ein problem oft könnten sie
den stoff nicht so gut vermitteln
insofern hat sie gleich zwei wünsche an
die politik der wünschen uns natürlich
definitiv mehr engagierte lehrer in
berlin und auch mehr dass quereinsteiger
in der gewissen pädagogik mehr geschult
werden im und in der unterricht struktur
und im umgang mit uns schüler in rolf
kemper ist politikwissenschaftler an der
uni bielefeld hat sich die wahlprogramme
der sechs im berliner parlament
vertretenden parteien angeschaut die
situation der lehrer ist durchaus thema
vor allem die rückkehr zur verbeamtung
sehen die parteien unterschiedlich die
großen parteien die spd und die cdu
möchten wieder vier beamten weil sie
sich davon versprechen dass mehr
lehrkräfte nach berlin kommen und dass
die qualität des unterrichts erhöht wird
die grünen und die linken lehnen das
nach wie vor ab bei den grünen gibt es
mit blick auf die
koalitionsverhandlungen
mittlerweile die tendenz dass man sich
das vorstellen kann die fdp lehnt als
marktwirtschaftlich ausgerichtete partei
die verbeamtung ab und die fdp plädiert
dafür der umgang mit den quereinsteigern
spielt ebenfalls eine rolle rolf kemper
hat auch hier unterschiede gefunden
die grünen sagen wir benötigen
quereinsteiger wir begrüßen allerdings
auch den einsatz der quereinsteiger weil
sie führen zu einer diversen schule die
fdp lehnt die quereinsteiger absagen das
ist eine übergangslösung die cdu möchte
quereinsteiger sagt aber wir müssen die
zahl wie grenzen wir müssen verträge zu
beginn befristen und wir brauchen
strenge maßnahmen die spd und die linken
unterstützen das programm quereinsteiger
einzustellen sagen aber wir müssen zu
beginn besser ausbilden und die fdp
möchte die zahl der quereinsteiger an
den schulen prozentual gerecht verteilen
leonie krüger ist gespannt was von den
plänen umgesetzt wird ob sie
verbesserungen als schülerin noch
erleben wird laut sie aber nicht
schließlich wird sie voraussichtlich in
anderthalb jahren fertig sein
[Musik]
berlins straßen sind voll knapp 3,7
millionen menschen leben hier in der
stadt um sie alle wollen unterwegs seien
mit autos mit bussen mit bahnen mit
fahrrädern und zu fuß wenn man der ein
verkehrs form ein bisschen mehr platz
geben will dann muss man einer anderen
was wegnehmen das sorgt für ständige
diskussion das ist auch nicht
ungefährlich hier in der stadt im
letzten jahr sind 50 menschen auf
berlins straßen gestorben und das trotz
aller corona beschränkung mobilität ist
ein ganz großes thema in berlin
wir treffen armin bad
[Musik]
in der für begleiter hat kein eigenes
auto und ist hauptsächlich mit dem rad
unterwegs da sieht er auch sein größtes
verkehrsproblemen die rücksichtslosen
auto war es gibt ganz nette autofahrer
aber die rücksichtslosen autofahrern sie
parken du auf der busspur sie reisen
einfach die tür auf hindert ihr der
gelbe riese von der bvg und dann musst
du noch bremsen schreien und versuchen
nicht vom fahrrad zu fallen also das ist
kreuzgefährlich trägt nicht auch maßlos
auf dieser radweg ist nagelneu noch
nicht mal richtig fertig armin ist einer
der ersten glücklichen hier
das gehalt
nur gibt es für ihn von solchen sicheren
spuren für räder viel zu wenig in der
stadt
kriegen wir müssen den platz einfach nur
sinnvoll nutzen also gerade jetzt auch
das beispiel bülowstraße da drüben ist
sie partner unter dem viadukt der u bahn
sie parken aber auch rechts am
straßenrand habe ich zwei spuren warum
es einfach die autos entweder und das
viadukt verbannen oder dug für radfahrer
und für ihre oder freigeben also einfach
vernünftige lösungen finden im
vernünftiges konzept wo beide zufrieden
sind und die leute die betroffen sind
mit an den tisch holen
politikwissenschaftler drf kemper hat
sich für uns die programme der parteien
für die wahl zum berliner
abgeordnetenhaus auch mit blick auf den
radverkehr angesehen bei motto wollen
die grünen dass das auto aus der
innenstadt heraus geführt wird sie
möchten das fahrrad und der pnv
weitgehend das auto ersetzen die spd
unterstützt die grünen dabei dass fahrer
aufzuwerten sagt aber gleichzeitig
müssen autoverkehr immer noch
ermöglichen die linken
positionieren sich auch pro
verkehrswende sagen aber dass das auto
nachrangig auch noch eine bedeutung
haben muss die afg fordert keine
einschränkung für autofahrer die cdu die
fdp machen das nicht ganz so extrem die
cdu sagt autofahrer müssen nach wie vor
in der innenstadt präsent sein wir
müssen aber auch den fahrradfahrern
bessere bedingungen schaffen und die fdp
bedroht die wahlfreiheit armin bat der
als flugbegleiter regelmäßig und gerne
auch zügig zum neuen flughafen ber muss
und auch sonst für längere strecken den
öffentlichen nahverkehr braucht wünscht
sich dass auch die außenbezirke besser
angebunden werden
du bist an den stadtrand minimum der
stunde stunde 30 unterwegs du kannst
froh sein wenn du durch fahren kannst
kannst du fast von überall her
durchfahren aber wenn du anders und muss
dann wieder umsteigen dann wieder auf
den bus dann wieder warten im sommer ist
ja alles noch kein problem aber lasst es
herbst werben winter werden es schneit
es stürmt und dann noch an den zugigen
bushaltestellen warten nicht wirklich
schnell armin barth hat schon per brief
gewählt weil er nicht sicher war wie am
wahltag sein dienstplan aussehen wird
und womöglich die wahl zu verpassen das
kommt für ihn nicht in frage
die wohnungskrise treibt viele auf die
straßen von berlin der grund hohe mieten
und angst vor verdrängung gerade hier in
berlin hat das internationale
finanzkapital nach der wende in ganz
großem stil eingekauft das
geschäftsmodell aufkaufen aufwerten und
wiederverkauf markt einfach zu gut
geklappt immer mehr menschen wurden aus
ihren kiezen vertrieben haben angst ihr
zuhause zu verlieren und weiter so ist
gehen sie gerade jetzt vor der wahl zu
tausenden wieder auf die straße und
fordern eine umkehr in der mieten und
wohnpolitik in dieser stadt vor zu hohen
mieten fürchtet sich auch julia sie lebt
in der kameruner straße 55 das haus soll
gerade verkauft werden was treibt euch
heute so kurz vor der wahl noch mal zur
lähmung diese volksfest zu kurz sagte
weil unser sind natürlich daran
interessiert dass unser haus nicht von
dem immobilienspekulanten gekauft wird
sondern entweder vom bezirk weil wir
milieus gebiet liegen oder von einer
genossenschaft das ist leider
superschwer
der stadtbezirk hatte offenbar kein geld
mehr um sein vorkaufsrecht auszuüben nun
versucht die mietergemeinschaft aus
eigener kraft das haus zu erwerben aber
auch der arbeiterbezirk berliner wedding
ist teuer geworden
es ist unbegreiflich wie ein marktwert
für ein haus aufgerufen werden kann bei
dem dann städtische
wohnungsbaugesellschaften oder
genossenschaften nicht mehr mitziehen
könnten die das geld nicht mehr dafür
haben die mieten haben sich hier in den
letzten jahren verdoppelt meint julia
sie zahlt schon elf euro kalt für ihre
unsanierte wohnung andere mit alten
verträgen zahlen noch sechs euro pro
quadratmeter
kauft der investor wird hier
grundsaniert die mietwohnungen werden
dann für viele unbezahlbar sein oder als
eigentumswohnungen angeboten bei uns ist
es so dass im haus so gut wie alle sich
nicht eigentum leisten können und als
mieter auch auf mieten angewiesen sind
die sich im fairen bereich das heißt wir
hatten an den mieten deckel also unter
diesen mieten decke leben bewegen aber
es ist deine wohnung nicht kaufen wollen
wollen schon aber ich habe das geld
dafür nicht also wir haben sehr wohl
angst vor der verdrängung an den
stadtrand und das ist für uns eigentlich
das allerschlimmste zu sagen man kann ja
neu bauen aber das ist hier unsere
heimat wir haben wir unseren kiez unsere
unsere festen strukturen freunde
dienstleistung arbeit was erwartest du
denn da von den politikern zur wahl soll
da mehr geld er den topf oder was wir so
den wunsch der wunsch ist auf jeden fall
dass das der bezirk quasi ein wenn ein
vorkaufsrecht hat dieses auch nutzen
kann wie auch immer also dass der
milieus als milieu schutz auch umgesetzt
werden kann in berlin werden immer mehr
wohngebiete zu besonders schützenswerten
milieu gebieten erklärt überall
schließen sich dann mieter zusammen
wünschen sich die stadt oder eine
genossenschaft als vermieter drf kemper
von der uni bielefeld hat sich für uns
angeschaut wie die politik auf die
forderung nach mehr kommunalem eigentum
reagiert die linken die grünen und die
spd also die koalitionsparteien betonen
alle wir möchten mindestens 50%
gemeinwohl orientiertes wohnen in berlin
ermöglichen die cdu die fdp und die fdp
lehnen das ab die cdu sagt wir brauchen
privaten wohnungsbau die fdp und die afg
kritisiert staatsdirigismus und haben
dort eine ausgesprochen andere programme
mieterin juli hofft dass er neuer senat
die öffentlichen finanzen so auffällt
dass die bezirke ihr vorkaufsrecht auch
wahrnehmen können oder wie am eckhaus in
ihrer straße eine genossenschaft das
geld zum kauf denn sie wir bleiben in
ihrem kiez ohne angst vor verdrängung
leben in ihrer stadt berlin